non
sa collègue bonjour
château welcome to die in
china
chers collègues c'est un grand honneur
pour moi de vous accueillir aujourd'hui
nous avons eu
un certain nombre de daube ce tacle à
pouvoir nous rencontrer à cause du peu
mais pour ce 18e cette 18 ème rencontre
des leaders des affaires étrangères pour
la russie inde et chine nous allons
nous allons traiter de différents sujets
et je vais vous faire un mot
d'introduction maintenant et je
laisserai la parole au ministre des
affaires étrangères wang li et à au
ministre des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov
pour commencer je voudrais remercier mes
collègues de russie de chine pour leur
soutien et la coopération
et comme je le dis au mois de septembre
et je tiens à remercier
la russie et la chine pour leur
participation
donc dans la conférence à la conférence
académique de notre pays
chers collègues je voudrais encore une
fois
réaffirmé l'engagement de l'inde pour
travailler à cette coopération entre nos
pays et dans l'ensemble de notre région
je crois que cette coopération
et la mise en place d'un climat
d'investissement de coopération matière
de science et de théologie et on va dire
pour l'éthique évidemment pourrait
contribuer significativement à la
croissance mondiale et à la paix et la
stabilité et cela correspond évidemment
à l'ensemble de
dé
l'ordre du jour que nous avons mises en
place
et lille est important ici de ne laisser
personne de côté nous avons
montré l'importance d'un monde
interconnecté
et cela fait partie de notre les mots de
notre ordre du jour
dans un état d'esprit de lait non aux
discriminations pour répondre ensemble
de concert aux défis qui se posent au
monde il ya aussi la question de l'accès
aux soins médicaux qui se pose
aujourd'hui pour nos peuples
et les
membres du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
membres permanents et non permanents
ont trouvé des solutions acceptables
acceptable pour l'ensemble des pays
de façon à rééquilibrer le monde dans un
esprit de multipolaire
et qui correspond aux
véritables à la réalité telle qu'elle
est sur le terrain
nous avons un partenariat important avec
l'afghanistan et l'inde est préoccupé
par l'évolution des derniers
des derniers événements
et nous espérons que le nouveau
gouvernement sera garantir la stabilité
sous l'égide de l'onu
nous avons fourni
cinquante cinq
mille tonnes de blé à l'afghanistan pour
lutter contre le risque de famine et
aider le peuple afghan à
se remettre sur pied sans intervention
extérieure sans ingérence
et en même temps invité tout éviter
toute
radicalisation religieuse et tout
tout danger pour la stabilité dans le
pays
je vous remercie pour votre attention
monsieur jay sean
monsieur lavoie c'est un honneur pour
moi de
m'expliquer de m'exprimer aujourd'hui
pour cette rencontre des ministres des
affaires étrangères de russie chine et
inde et tout le médian et fit évidemment
la situation tourne vu kobe 19 pose un
certain nombre de problèmes et cela est
un défi pour l'ensemble du monde
donc tout cela nécessite un certain
nombre d'ajustements dans la politique
internationale
et en même temps il faut éviter un
protectionnisme il faut
pouvoir travailler ensemble
puisque les défis qui se posent
aujourd'hui pour le développement la
croissance sont très claires et il me
semble que la situation
internationale
suppose aujourd'hui des transformations
profondes et les grands pays qui ont une
influence demander qui sont les plus
représentatives des marchés émergents et
des économies en croissance
et nous avons donc des intérêts ici en
commun ils sont clairs pour nos paies et
c'est une responsabilité importante sur
nos épaules est face aux évolutions du
ce de ce siècle nos trois pays
[Musique]
ont des intérêts
mutuelle à respecter
mais le parti communiste de chine
[Musique]
lors de ces réunions préparatoires au
congrès a validé cette expérience
historique
et a confirmé une même une résolution
était adoptée ici et qui s'appuie sur
les grandes orientations
pour la conduite à suivre à l'avenir
face aux changements internationaux et
l'objectif de développement pour la
chaîne tout en maintenant d'excellentes
relations avec les grands partenaires
que sont la russie et d'inde dans un
esprit de solidarité et de coopération
et cet esprit
a montré que cette responsabilité de nos
pays important
doit donner un message positif à
l'ensemble du monde et en promouvant la
démocratie dans à l'échelle
internationale et en soutenant la
stabilité et la paix au niveau mondial
dans ce monde en changement nos trois
pays peuvent continuer en proposant des
solutions
et j'attends évidemment un grand échange
d'opinions entre nos pays et pour que
notre réunion soit tout à fait et
fructueuse
cela doit coopérer doit faciliter la
coopération pour notre pays
merci m
la parole est à monsieur lavrov
chers collègues chers amis avant tout je
tiens à vous saluer et à remercier le
gouvernement indien pour l'organisation
de cette réunion des ministres affaires
étrangères de russie chine et inde qui
pour des raisons évidentes se fait en
régime de visioconférence
aujourd'hui notre échange sur les
questions importantes de l'actualité est
importante sur le plan sur le fond des
turbulences eux qui ne cesse d'augmenter
sur l'arène internationale dans les
conditions de poursuite de la pandémie
le système des relations internationales
se trouve face à des défis importants
sur les plans socio économique et ce
virus a
frappé la gouvernance mondiale
et toutes les mesures isolées
isolationniste se sont trouvés
aujourd'hui
dans une situation elles doivent être
revues
aujourd'hui dans cette politique
mondiale et régionale nous avons donc
des questions de sécurité d'
architecture de la paix dans la sur le
continent asiatique mais aussi dans la
région
de l'océan pacifique tout cela est
important pour nos pays et le
développement de cette coopération au
sein de notre cas est une partie
importante de la mise en place d'un
ordre
du mouvement de plus multipolaire plus
démocratique et plus équilibrée avec
tout en travaillant avec l'onu
et cet aspect de multipolarité d'égalité
d'égalité de droits des pays est très
important
nous refusons tout protectionnisme
économique et l' usage des sanctions
unilatérales à
connotation politique nous travaillons
de concert sur les l'ordre du jour
international dans le cadre de l'onu du
g20
des brics et nous travaillons sur
l'ensemble des mécanismes de coopération
dans la zone asiatique eurasiatique et
pacifique ceux-ci or aujourd'hui de
travail de discuter de tous les thèmes
qui ont été citées par nous et je suis
convaincu que cette ce travail nous
permettra de mettre en valeur un
potentiel très important et c'est
justement ce qui correspond à ce format
russie chine inde je vous remercie